الان بحسب سي ان تم وضع الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب تحت او قيد الاعتقال
تم وضع الرئيس الامريكي السابق قيد
الاعتقال في هذه اللحظات حسب سي ان ان
احمد
بلديه كان يكشف امامه كل شيء تكشف امامه
كل الوثائق المتعلقه بالامن القومي
الامريكي وليس هناك درجه من السريه محظور
على الرئيس الامريكي للاطلاع عليها فهذا
ما يجعل هذه القضيه قضيه حساسه للغايه ما
يجعل هذه التهم خطيره للغايه لانه رئيس
يحتفظ في جوفه في ذاكرته في مخيلته عبد
السلام باسرار الولايات المتحده يحتفظ بها
وزد على ذلك انه احتفظ بالوثائق بالاف
الوثائق لا يحق له الاحتفاظ بناء على حسب
كما تقول وطني وزاره احمد اذا سمحت لوزاره
العدل الان بحسب نيويورك تايم تقول بان
عمليه اعتقال ترامب
ومساعدته اكتملت وفقا للاجراءات القضائيه
اذا نذكر بهذا الخبر ايضا عمليه اعتقال
ترامب ومساعدته تمت او اكتملت وفقا
للاجراءات القضائيه نعود اليك احمد
لا هذا تصريح يبدو فيه من الغموض اكثر مما
فيه من الوضوح ماذا يعني حسب الاجراءات
القانونيه هل وضعت الاصفار في يده كما
يوضع توضع الاسفار في يد الاخرين هل تم
اخذ صوره المتعلقه بالاعتقال كما تؤخذ صور
الاخرين تصريح وزاره العدل اذا كان اذا
كان ارادت منه ان تقول بانه لم يخضع الى
معامله
فيها امتياز على الامريكي الاخرين فهذا
يعني انه ان الاسفار وضعت في يده عبد
السلام وكانت التصريحات والتسريبات في
البدايه تقول بان الاطفال لم توضع لم توضع
في يد الرئيس الامريكي السابق
بمعزل عن هذا التصريح والان رهن الاعتقال
عبد السلام سواء وضعت الاصفاد في يده ام
لم توضع في لحظه تاريخيه كبيره للغايه